you know Obama used to say about the war
on terror we know we don't have to just
get out of Iraq we have to change our
mindset don't we have to change our
mindset about how we treat people I have
never once heard for example a Western
doctor say to me when I went to him to
see about anything what do you eat what
yeah is it that important
I mean why no what's wrong with you if
you're eating Funyuns all day isn't or
what do you smoke well smoke they ask
you about oh I see what nursing you know
really think that's bad for you do you
well so multi [ __ ] with me done sixty
million operations year what does the
week your most likely have an operation
your life this is why I wrote the book
it's the last week of your life right
and that's the week where you're getting
no benefit at all you're getting is the
pain you know it's time before you
recover and get any benefit from surgery
we are a society where we are unwilling
to recognize often that people are
coming to the end of their lives and
make it a normal part of our life to
understand what are people's priorities
but isn't that why Obamacare has death
panels in it right I think we finally
show they don't I think we are finally
graduating from that debate right but
but you point out that the the study of
geriatrics is practically absent for
medical school yeah so you know number
of elderly are rising in the country and
and so you would think oh we must be
training more geriatricians and medical
students must be learning geriatrics
ninety-seven percent of medical students
have no training in geriatrics and we're
now training fewer geriatricians than we
did a decade ago but America in in the
world is unique about how we treat old
people in general right I mean no other
country warehouses them like we do we in
what we do we institutionalize our old
people we put them in homes I know we're
the best country in the world were the
most exceptional but no other country
does that and and when you I've read
this from what you said there the
complaints about nursing homes
our I was very surprised about these
complaints because I didn't think these
were prisons they complain about the
food they complain they can't smoke and
they complain they're not allowed to
have porn yeah haven't they earned it I
mean some of these people fought in
World War two yeah we we've gone from a
country where you know 1950s most of us
died at home to where today it's only
17% die at home we're at a point where
83% of us die in institutions and the
reality of life in nursing homes or in
assisted living is that you know our
focus is on safety and you think that's
such a good thing you know I'm going to
put my parent in a in a place and I'm
going to go in I can say you know is it
safe but but someone who talked about it
was like to live in a nursing home said
to me you know safety is what we want
for those we love
but autonomy is what we want for
ourselves right and we're not thinking
about that when it comes to our parents
yeah I I wonder if the baby boomers who
put their parents in these homes would
do it themselves cuz I think you're
gonna take away their porn from their
cold dead hands that's right that's
right now you go into these places
you'll you'll see they built around a
nursing station and instead there are
these radical places that write about
that are starting to build them around
the kitchen and in in that kitchen is a
refrigerator and you're allowed to go in
the refrigerator and get whatever food
you want and that is a radical idea
because people say well it's not safe
how can you let someone go to the fridge
and get you know a diabetic might get a
soda pop out of the out of the fridge
it's it's dangerous and getting to the
place where we understand you know
people have priorities besides just
living longer they want freedoms and
those freedoms are how we have some
meaning in life there